[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
على موقع القمعي والاحتجاجات ايران تغير
قائد الامن الداخلي وانتقادات غربيه
لاحكام الاعدام
جدا تستعد للاكس بول الحجه 2023 اكثر من
400 اتفاقيه متوقعه لتطوير تجربه الحجاج
معيشيا وثقيا
السعوديه من اعلى دول العالم اصابه بامراض
القلب 40,000 اصابه جديده في كل
رابعه ايضا
جوله في مهرجان الحمضيات بالعلام 200,000
شجره منتجه ودعم للمزارعين المحلي
على واقع الامطار في الرياض الرابعه توثيق
امتلاء بحيره ام شقوق امام جبل طارق
على وقع الاحتجاجات عين المرشد الايراني
2004 وحتى 2006 وكان ردان ضمائر الحرس
الثوري خلال فتره الحرب الايرانيه
العراقيه انتقل بعدها الى قوه الامن
الداخلي كما فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
عقوبات على رادان في سبتمبر من عام 2010
بسبب الانتهاكات الحاده لحقوق الانسان
ياتي تعينك قائد جديد للام في ظل تناول
التقارير الصحفيه محليه عن وجود رفض من
بعض القيادات لتنفيذ اوامر امين
محكمه ايرانيه حكم الاعدام شنقا في حق
متظاهرين شاركا في الاحتجاجات المتواصله
في البلاد وفقا لوكاله رويترز فقد واجهت
المحكمه تهاما مزعومه بقتل مسؤول امنيه
اثناء الاحتجاجات لكل منه محمد مهدي
البالغ من العمر 22 عاما وسيد محمد حسين
البالغ من العمر 20 عاما
عمليه الاعدام بحق السجينين محمد مهدي
كرمي وسيد محمد حسيني اثاره ردود فعل
دوليه غاضبه جدا في هذا السياق قالت هيئه
حقوق الانسان في ايران ان تاخر المجتمع
الدولي في الرد على اعدام الايرانيين يعزز
عمليات اعدام المحتجين في البلاد وصفاء
اهالي ضحايا الطائره الايراني من اعدم
الشابين بلا محامي في ايران وصفهم
بالارهابيين كما اشار المتحدث باسم اهالي
ضحايا الطائره الاوكرانيه لا وجودي او
وجوب طردي سفراء ايران في الخارج بسبب
اعدام
جاتا ايه قال رئيس البرلمان النرويجي
مسعود قرر خاني ان ايران اعدمت محمد مهدي
كرمي وسيد محمد حسين بدون مسوغ قانوني
اشار مسعود قرخاني الى ان اخر كلمات محمد
مهدي قبل اعدامه كانت ابي لا تخبر امي ان
عقوبته هي الاعدام
قبل حادثه الاعدام
بان محمد ريقي احد جرح الجمعه الداميه في
زهدان جنوب شرقيه ايران توفي بعد 97 يوما
بسبب شده الاصابات
اصيب برصاص القوات الامنيه الايرانيه في
البطن والكلى والرئه والكبد
كانت شهدت مدينه سلندج عاصمه كردستان
ايران تظاهرات واسعه شعله فيها المحتجون
النيران في الشوارع ودعوا الى الاحتجاج في
كل انحاء ايران غدا الاحد
[تصفيق]
فيروس
المتحده عقوبات على شخصيات الايرانيه لها
علاقه بشركه لتصنيع الطائرات المسيره التي
استخدمتها روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا
واتهام وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ايران
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا عبر تزويدها
بهذه الطائره
عقوبه جديده تفرضها الولايات المتحده على
ايران سعيا منها لعرقله برنامج تصنيع
المسير العسكريه الايرانيه وزاره الخزانه
وضعت اسماء السته رؤساء تنفيذي واعضاء في
مجلس اداره شركه القدس لصناعه الطيران
والتابعه للحرس الثوري في لائحه العقوبه
الشركه التي وضعت في عده لوائح عقوبات
امريكيه وبريطانيه منذ عام 2013
مسؤوله عن تصميم وانتاج طائره بدون طيار
للاستخدام العسكري
وفي ما كان في موسكو استخدامها لمسيرات
ايرانيه الصنع اقر الطهران ارسالها لعدد
من الطائرات بدون طيار لروسيا قبل بدء
الحرب المستهدفون بالعقوبات الامريكيه هم
سيد حجه الله قريش رئيس مجلس اداره شركه
القدس والمسؤول رفيع المستوى بوزاره
الدفاع قاسم دم فانديان العضو المنتدب
بشركه القدس وعضو مجلس الاداره اضافه الى
حامد رضا شريف طهراني ورضا خلقي ورضا
نيازي انجيلي وولي ارلاني زادا بموجب هذه
العقوبات سيتم تجميد كل اصولهم الامريكيه
اذا وجدت ويمنع بشكل عام
الامريكيون من التعامل معهم ويخاطر من
ينخرطون في معاملات معينه معهم
بتعريض انفسهم لعقوبات ايضا
خطوه اخرى اذا تخطوها الحكومه الامريكيه
في اتجاه خنق قدرات التصنيع العسكري
الايراني كجزء من استراتيجيتها لاجهاض
برنامج طهران النووي
العربيه
للنظام الايراني بمقتل شخص وجرح اثنين
اخرين بعد اطلاق نار داخل القسم الكيميائي
في شركه غاشقران للنفط والغاز مشيره الى
ان موظفا فتح النار من مسدس على موظفي
القسم دون معرفه الدوافع
واضافت الوكاله بانه تمم ملاحقه شخص
المسؤول عن انطلاق النار واعتقاله من قبل
شرطه المنطقه
تستضيفوا مدينه جده غربيه السعوديه مؤتمر
ومعرض خدمات الحج والعمره اكسبو الحاج
خلال الفتره التاسع الى الثاني عشر من
يناير الجاريه ومن المتوقع ان يشهد اكسبو
الحاج57 دوله تتناول جلسات المؤتمر عده
موضوعات من ابرازها خدامه خدمات النقل
والاعاش للحجاج والفراسه الاستثماريه فضلا
عن اثراء تجربه ضيوف الرحمن الثقافيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا نائب وزير الحج
والعمره الدكتور عبد الفتاح نشاط دكتور
عبد الفتاح اهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
او لما الجديد في في المؤتمر مؤتمر الحج
الدولي واكسبو الحاج في نسخته الثانيه هذا
العام
حياك الله استاذ خالد
النسخه الثانيه لمعرض ومعتمر الحج كل شيء
جديد
تحدثنا عن المجالات التي يغطيها المؤتمر
فهو مجالات كبيره جدا تغطي كامل رحله همم
الحاج من بدايه اصوله او قبل الوصوله الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى عوده مرورا
بجميع مراحل همم رحله الاسرائيليه
والالمانيه اذا تحدثنا عن عدد المشاركين
العدل الكبير جدا ذكرت انه فعلا 57 او 58
دوله مشاركه من اصحاب المعالي رؤساء
ووزراء همم الجهات المختصه بالحج والاوقاف
في دبلهم بل انه يتعدل عدد الى اكثر من
120 دوله ارسلوا مكاتب شلون الحاج لعقد
ال- ال- همم الاتفاقيات تحت القبه في خلال
الاربع ايام القادمه اذا تحدثنا عن عدد
المتحدثين عدد
كبير جدا من المتحدثين حياتك انك نتحدث عن
اكثر من 70 متحدث في 25 جلسه متخصصه وكل
ما هو موجود في معرض ومعتمر هذا هذه السنه
وفي النسخه الجديده لهذه السنه فيعتبر
جديد ولم يكن لوزاره الحج والعمره اي
حقيقه همم
عمل بهذا الكبر وبهذا الحجم من التنوع من
العدد المشاركه ممكن تعطيني فكره عن
الاتفاقيات اللي راح تتوقع مع في تحت
القبه يعني الحديث عن اكثر من 400 اتفاقيه
هذا كبير كبيره
صحيح طبعا احنا اعتدنا في السنوات الماضيه
وقبل الجايحه ياتون مكاتب شؤون الحج لهم
القائمين وممثل الحجاج جميع انحاء العالم
على مدار تقريبا شهرين لتوقيع اتفاقيات مع
شركات والمؤسسات المتخصصه في تقديم
الخدمات اثناء الحج
قبه واحده في مؤتمر واحد وفي معرض واحد
يتم فيه استعراض كافه الخدمات من كل
الشركات المقدمه للخدمه وبالتالي سنقدم
منظومه متكامله وبالسلامه في نفس الوقت
تسهم في تطوير تجربه ضيوف الرحمن
والاستفاده من جميع الرؤى والافكار
المختصين واستشار المستقبل طبعا هيكون فيه
هناك حديثنا العديد من الاطروحات الجديده
والابداعيه لسيتم طرحها خلال هذه المؤتمر
وهذه فرصه حقيقه اللي مكاتب شؤون الحج
وممثلين الحجاج اللي همم
الاستعراضها والوقوف عليها مباشره والتاكد
منه حقيقي تاني من انه الخدمه التي
يطلبونها يكون مقدم لهم في فتره الحج
دكتور
نبحث كذلك على التنوع والتنافسيه بين جميع
المقدمه
من هذا المؤتمر الى الطرح الموجود فيه من
المتحدثين من الجلسات التي تقام اعطينا
مثال يعني هو النسخه الثانيه فبالتالي في
النسخه الاولى على سبيل المثال كيف
استفدتوا من التوصيات او نتائج هذا الموسم
طبعا في كل في المؤتمر السابق الى يعني
اذا كان في السنه الماضيه كان هناك تقديم
بعض الافكار الابداعيه وهي تم استفاده
منها في موسم السنه الماضيه والاله الحمد
سجلت بعض الافكار حقيقه ردود فعل ايجابيه
هذه السنه من خلال التركيز على استخدام
تحديدا التقنيات ال- همم التقنيه المستقبل
والتقنيات المبتكره همم اكيد هيكون فيها
اشراك للمبتدرين ورواد الاعمال وهذا كله
يعزز جوده الخدمات القدمه في الحج على قدر
ما نستطيع ان احنا في وزاره الحج والعمره
ايجاد بيئه ممكنه للقطاع الخاص والقطاع
غير الربحي ل- همم التواجد ونشر ابداعاتهم
ابتكاراتهم خلال المعرض على قد ما حقيقه
انه يحقق اهداف المعرض وهي تجويد الخدمه
وفي نفس الوقت همم التنافسيه
همم جيده بين جميع اطراف مقدمه خدمه
والمستفيدي من الخدمه
مؤخراطلقت همم عمليه تسجيل حجاج الداخل
هذه لاول مره في هذا التوقيت بتوقيت مبكر
تقريبا قبل التوقيت المعتاد لاطلاق هذه
العمليه بالعاده في شوال اليوم تقريبا قبل
اربعه الى خمسه اشهر من هذا الموعد
المعتاد
الفائده يعني من الانطلاقه في هذا الوقت
المبكر
السنه الماضيه السنه الماضيه كانت صحينا
عدد الحجاج مليون حاج لكن اعطنا رياحيه
بالعداد الجيد
للحج ولله الحمد سجلت معظم المؤشرات نجاح
كبير جدا بعد الحج مباشره بدانا الاستعداد
للحج الموسم القادم الى 1440 الان نحن
احييتنا نقطف ثمار
التنسيق المتكامل الجهود التنسيقيه بين
جميع القطاعات نحن نعلم جميعا ان اكتم 35
جهه حكوميه وجهه عامه تعمل لي في المضيوف
الرحمن التنسيق المبكر همم على مستوى ان
كان على المستوى الاستراتي لوضع الخطه
الاستراتيجيه بالاضافه الى الخطه
التنفيذيه هذه كلها سعادتنا عليه انه نحن
نبدا همم تنفيذ الخطرنا همم بشكل مبكر
طبعا يعني طرحنا للمناصه اكيد هيكون في
هناك معلومات يكون في تنوع همم كبير جدا
في طرح باقات همم الحج التواصل المبكر بين
مقدمه الخدمه وبين الحجاج هي كله اثر كبير
جدا في همم الاستفاده من متطلباتهم
والوقوف عليها والتنفيذها بوقت مبكر هذه
كل احد يساعدنا على ان يكون الخدمه ان شاء
الله تقدم في فتره موسم القادم باعلى
مستوى وهذه هي احد الاسباب التي جعلتني
انه احنا ننتهي من
استعدادات الحج وهذا ليس فقط على مستوى
حجاج الداخل ولكن حتى على مستوى حجاج
الخارجي
دكتور شكرا جزيلا لك على تواجدك معنا وزير
الحج والعمره الدكتور عبد الفتاح
رابعه بعد قليل
خمسه او 36 طن من المستلزمات الطبيه تعبر
منفذ الوديع لدعم مراكز الغسيل الكلوي
اهلا بكم من جديد السعوديه من اكثر الدول
في ارتفاع معدلات الاصابه بامراض القلب
والشرايين التاجيه هذا ما دعى المجلس
الصحي السعودي لاطلاق معايره جديده
للتعامل معه المصابين حيث تعدوا امراض
القلب المسبب الاول للوفاه في السعوديه
بنسبه تتخطى 37% من اجمالي الوفيات واثبتت
الدراسات ان 54% من مواطني السعوديه ما
بين 30 الى 70 عاما يعانون من ارتفاعا
شديد في الكوليسترول وهو العامل الاخضر في
الاصابه بامراض القلب دراسات اخرى
متلازمه الشرايين التاجيه والازمات القلب
يتصل الى 40 الف حاله جديده كل عام في
السعوديه فقط وان المرضى السعوديه يصابون
بمتلازمه الشرايين الترجيع عند عمر 58 سنه
وهو يعد اصغر ب 10 سنه عن معدل الاعمار
والعالم
مجددا ينضم الينا مدير عام المركز الوطني
للقلب الدكتور عبد عادل عبد القادر طاش
دكتور عادل مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
دكتور يعني اول شيء اذا ما توقفنا عن عن
عند الارقام
37 همم في المئه امراض القلب هي المسبب
الاول للوفاه السعوديه 54% من مواطن
السعوديه يعانون من ارتفاع الشديد وغيرها
من الارقام التي وردت في هذا التقرير
اعتقد انها ارقام خطيره وربما يعني لم تصل
بشكل مفاجئ كانت مبنيه على تراكمات في عده
سنوات ماضيه ليس كذلك
نعم اولا شكرا استاذ خالد على الاضافه
وسعيد بوجودكم ولكن حقيقه يعني زي ما
تفضلتم في التقرير السابق
لابد ان ااه يعني ااا نبدا بالعمل الكبير
والحديث على الحد من عوامل خطوره الاصابه
بممتازمه الشريان التاجي او الجلطات
القلبيه الحاده في المجتمع السعودي فحقيقه
زي ما تفضلتوا في التقرير المجتمع السعودي
مختلف عن المجتمع الغربي من الاشياء
الحقيقه اللي احنا لاحظناها ما بين
المجتمع الغربي وما بين المجتمع السعودي
بانه المجتمع السعودي بان انه نرى مرضى
مصابين بجلطات قلبي حاده في اعمار صغيره
واثبتت الدراسات بانه الاعمار همم اصغر ب
10 سنين يعني احنا في المجتمع السعودي
نصاب بالجلطات القلبيه الحاده بما يعادل
10 سنين همم همم اصغر من المجتمعات
الغربيه اقل نعم وهذا يدل على انه عوامل
خطوره عندنا اشد وعوامل خطوره عندنا تاخذ
فتره تاخير ما نتعامل معها حتى تصاب ليش
ليش وصلنا الى هذه الارقام
مع الاشاره انا اتحدث عن الموضوع لقيت انه
القضيه صار لها سنوات يعني يعني تقريبا
قبل ثلاثه او اربعه او خمس سنوات
نعم صحيح والحقيقه يعني خلال الفتره
الماضيه خلال السنوات الماضيه اخذنا يعني
خطوات جدا جدا ممتازه منها على سبيل
المثال اللجنه او اللجنه الوطنيه لمكافحه
التبغ قللت من همم استخدام او التدخين
بنسبه جيده في المجتمع السعودي لسه عندنا
مشوار ولسه عندنا شوط حلو قطعنا شوط ولكن
عندنا اشواط اخرى ولكن اللجنه الوطنيه
برنامج جوده الحياه وهمم يعني سنه المدن
اا زادت من اماكن المشي وممارسه الرياضه
وايضا ال- ال- الوزاره الصحه بوجود
العيادات الصحيه الاوليه او مراكز الصحيه
الاوليه زاد كل ممتاز بس الارقام مرضى نعم
تقول غير كده اليوم عن 40 الف حاله جديده
في كل عام في السعوديه فقط
وبرجعلك لنفس السؤال ليش احنا بتزيد عندنا
الحالات بهذا الشكل
والله يا حقيقه انه احنا يعني زي ما يعني
قلت لك في البدايه ان احنا اخذنا قطعنا
اشواط في بعضها في السكري في التدخين في
ارتفاع ضغط الدم في انسنه المدن وجوده
الحياه وزياده همم
الجوده الغذاء ولكن في جانب من الجوانب
الحقيقه مازلنا نعاني من هو اللي هو
ارتفاع الكوليسترول همم من الملاحظ بانه
54% من ال- همم المواطنين السعوديين ما
بين 30 الى 70 سنه مصابين بالارتفاع
الشديد في الكوليسترول ونعني هنا
بالكولسترول اللي هو الكوليسترول قليل
الكثافه الكوليسترول الضار
والحقيقه هذا بيسبب ما زال عندنا بيسبب
اشكاليه
وان احنا عندنا في المجلس الصحي السعودي
وفي وزاره الصحه لدينا الان حملات توعويه
بنصل للناس
بالاكل
بنسبه عاليه من الدهون والكوليسترو التالي
هذه الارقام تتوام مع طبيعتنا وثقافتنا في
الاكل ولا في اسباب ثانيه
لا طبعا هو في اسال اكل سبب مسبب ولكن
مسبب فرعي في مسبب رئيسي اللي هو وجود
نسبه كبيره من المجتمع السعودي عندهم
ارتفاع الكوليسترول الوراثي او ما نسميه
بفاميليا الهايبر كوليستروليميه همم
هتروزايز فاميليا هايبر كوليستروليميا
واللي نحتاج همم حقيقه انه احنا نبذل
مجهود اكبر
لاكتشاف وعلاجه
والمساله انه ايش بالنسبه لتفاعل
الكوليسترول الوراثي له علاج وفي همم يعني
احنا نستطيع التحكم بنسبه الكوليسترول
بشكل كبير جدا فمثلا على سبيل المثال
عندنا الادويه ال- ال- همم اللي نسبه
الكوليسترول عاده هذه نستخدمها في الوقايه
الاوليه وبعدين بعد كده المرضى اذا جاوبوا
جلطات قلبي حاده نسبه اللي يرجع بجلطات
قليبيه حاده اخرى ثانيه وثالثه ورابعه
خلال الاربعه سنوات بعد الجلطه الاولى
تقريبا واحد الى ثلاثه يعني يعني ثلث
المرضى بيرجع ثاني كيف نحن نستطيع ان نقلل
هذه النسبه بشكل جيد وبشكل ممتاز انه نحنا
نقلل من الكوليسترول الضار الى اقل من 55
مرام فاحنا عندنا حمله باذن الله سنتقل
قريبا من المجلس الصحي السعودي ممثلا
بمركز الوطني للقلب اللي هي حمله 55 لجميع
المرضى اللي هم تم تشخيصهم بمتلازمه
الشريان التاجي ان احنا نبغى نصل
بالكوليسترول الضار الى رقم 55 وعندنا
الادويه التي تساعدنا على هذا طبعا هي مش
ادويه فقط همم
الاكل همم او الغذاء الحركه وطبيعه هذا
طبيعه الحياه وجوده الحياه وايضا الى اي
مدى هذه الطريقه هذه المعايير الجديده
اللي راح تعتمدوها من ناحيه الطريقه
العلاجيه
بالاضافه الى خطتكم الاخرى يعني ممكن تقلل
من من هذه الاعداء يعني الاعداد الكبيره
اليوم
لو التقينا ان شاء الله بعد المعايير
انا اعتقد اذا التقينا بعد سنه بنكون باذن
الله في وضع افضل بكثير من ناحيه عدد
المرضى المصابين بالجلطات القلبيه الحاده
عدد المرضى المصابين بجلطات قلبيه حاده
متكرره ونسبه الكوليسترول في الدم همم
طبعا احنا المعايير هذه همم المعني بها
الحقيقه هو الممارس الصحي طبعا يعني امراض
القلب والشرايين همم لا ياتون فقط
لاطباء القلب ولكن ياتوا لي اطباء الرعايه
الصحيه الاوليه اطباء الباطنيه واطباء
الطوارئ واحنا حقيقه عنينا في هذه
المعايير بانه احنا نبسط المساله بحيث انه
ليس فقط طبيب القلب يستفيد منه ولكن طبيب
القلب طبيب الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه طبيب
الباطنيه العامه وطبيب الطوارئ بحيث ان
احنا كلنا نتعاون ونتظافر الجهود بانه
والله اذا جاء المريض احنا فعلا نفصل
كلولسترول ونعرف ايش هي المعايير وكم الحد
اللي احنا لازم نحافظ عليه بالنسبه
لكولسترول يعني التوت الكوليست الاول
كوليسترول الكلي وايضا الكوليسترول الضار
اللي هو اللودن سيتي لايف وبروتين ال دي
ال همم وهذا يعني احنا حتى نبغى نبه
الساده المشاهدين بانه اذا رحت للطبيب
واخذت تحليل الكوليسترول ابحث عن الال دي
ال وشف الرقم واسال الطبيب هل هذا هو
الرقم هذا التاركت هذا هو الهدف اللي انا
المفروض اصل له او احتاج او اعمل شيء اخر
شكرا لكم ان شاء الله نلتقي بعد سنه باذن
الله واحنا نبقى نقرا ارقام مختلفه ويمكن
نتكلم عن طرق نجاح هذه الاستراتيجيه وهذه
شكرا جزيلا لك مدير عام المركز الوطني
للقلب جدا الدكتور عادل عبد القادر طاش
انا مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه عن عبوري اربع شاحنات المحمله
باكثر من 36 طن من المستلزمات والمحاليل
الطبيه الخاصه بالغسيل الكلوي وذلك عبر
منفذ الوديعه الحدود مع اليمن لتوزيعها
على مراكز الغسيل الكلوي في اليمن كما ان
ذلك جزء من 15 شاحنه ستتولى ايضا خلال
دخولها لليمن خلال الايام القادمه
تساولات عده حول هيئه الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه
في السعوديه التي تقترب من اتمام عامها
الخامس عن ادوارها عن ما تقدمه من خدمات
لاكثر من مليون و 400 الف شخص من ذوي
الاعاقه العربيه كانت طرحت معاناه الاشخاص
ذوي الاعاقه في الثالث والعشرين من ديسمبر
الماضي
ما الى علمي في لقاء قريب التقيت مع احد
المسؤولين فيها يقولوا قبل ثلاثه شهور توه
يتم تعيين احد المسؤولين فيهم لوضع
استراتيجيه للهيئه بعد خمس سنوات
المعاقين مع الاسف مع وجود الهيئه انه الى
الان يعني وقد اكون مخطئ في هذا التصور او
الفم الهيئه لم تفهم دورها الاساسي الذي
انشئت من اجل يعني الهيئه استاذ خالد الان
همم دورها من انشات الى يومك توقيع
اتفاقيات توقيع اتفاقيه مع
المحلات توقع اتفاقيه مع همم جهات معينه
ما تفيد المعقيله من قريب ولا من بعيد همم
كان له مبادره يعني يتتاخرون بها كثيرا
وهي اطلاق السبت البنفسجي بنفسجي هذا يقدم
تخفيضات في في المغاسل في المطاعم يوم
واحد في السنه تمام ويقول لك والله اليوم
الواحد هو ما تلح لان فيه بعض الاماكن
تقدم خدمات او تخفيضات لمده ثمانيه ايام
همم لكن الهيئه مع الاسف ثم بدات الهيئه
تبادر توقيع اتفاقيات مع البنوك توقيعه
فقط هذا هذا ليس دورا الهيئه الهيئه فيما
نفهم نحن همم
دورها تشريعي رقابي لكل الوزارات والجهات
المعنيه بخدمه ذوي الاعاقه وبالتالي دورك
اشمل واكبر واهم من قضيه انك تتوقع
اتفاقيات او تتبنى بعض احياء مبادرات لذوي
الاعاقه تبن مبادره جاهز قهوه الاخ محمد
الشريف وتبنه مبادره عمار همم
للموهوبين وكانهم همم اصبحوا انت ما لم
يستقيم ابدا لا انا ولا زملائي الى الان
الكل يتسائل ما شفنا الا الان بعد خمس
سنواتها اي همم عمل يذكر همم او يشفع
للهيئه وجودها في هذا المكان
فيديوهات تنام لرياضه اخصائي الاعلام
والتواصل الاجتماعي بهيئه رعايه الاشخاص
ذوي الاعاقه راكان
شكرا على وجودكم
سلامات
وجودنا هنا اليوم ان شاء الله لتوضيح يعني
ادور هيا ومهامه قد يكون يمكن في خلط في
للبعض في عدم فهم دور الهيئه واختصاصاتهم
طبعا يمكن وجودين مثل ما قلت لك ما راح
يكون والله رد على اي شخص قد ما يكون هو
توضيح تفضل طبعا هي هي انشات عام 1439 لكن
تشكل اعضاء من سيدار وعين او الرئيس تنفيذ
في في عام 1440 زي ما انت عارف يعني
الموضوع
اربع سنوات
ولا واحد تنظيميه هذه يبغى لها وقت فيها
الحين لين ما يتشكل
السلم الوظيفي وطقم التوظيف طبعا الان
يعني الى الى الاسبوع الماضي وصل عدد
موظفين الى 70 موظف زي ما انت عارف اول
سنتين ترى ما كان يتعدى عند موظفين الخمس
موظفين همم طبعا الدور الهيئه هو التشريعي
السياسات والاستراتيجيات والانظمه ف بدانا
في العمل على الادغام حقوق الاشخاص ذوي
الاعاقه اللي هو النظام السابق نظام رعايه
المعوقين لصدر عام 1421 فبدات العمل على
النظام الجديد واللي ان شاء الله راح يصير
في الايام القادمه مش اهم ملامح هذا الحجر
الاساسي شويه
همم هو حقيقه سندوركم انتم في الهيئه هو
وضع كما قال الاخ يحيى وكما هو وارد ايضا
في يعني نص نص نظام الهيئه اللي هو
الانظمه التشريعات التسهيلات الخدمات اللي
ممكن تقدمه بالتعاون مع الجهات الحكوميه
فصل لي انت اليوم وش اللي بيتغير في
النظام الجديد لحقوقناها طيب مثل ماذا
موجود نظام نظام
المملكه
كويس
في شتى المجالات في مجال العمل في مجال
التعليم في مجال التوظيف في مجال الصحه في
مجال الرياضه وفي مجال الترفيه فهذا اي حق
خلاص بقى يكون هذا المتجر هذا النظام طيب
راكان خلينا نقول لكم يحيى مش اول شخص او
هو الشخص الوحيد اللي يتكلم في هذا
الموضوع
من خلال ايضا لقاءاتنا ونواحد من الناس
يمكن اللي اضمن من المعاقين وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه
انا ابغى اتكلم عن الحقوق والواجبات
وغيرها من الامور كثير يقولوا احنا ما
لمسنا اي تغيير كان في اعمال كبيره معلقه
من خلال الوضع تنظيمات التشريعات جديده
التعامل مع الهيئات مع الجهات الجهات
الحكوميه فيما يتعلق بحقوق بحقوقهم في
حياتهم اليوميه من خلال العمل وغيرها لكن
ما في اثر واضح حتى الان واربعه سنوات
قصير فبالتالي يعني من المسؤول عن هذه
النظر السلبيه
الاشخاص دوله
كثير من القرارات اللي تصدر من الجهه
الحكوميه ترا خلفيه لما اتكلم عن قرار
الوصول الشامل الذئاب الجهاد الحكوميه
الخاصه بتطبيق معايير الوصول الشامل ترى
خلفك طبعا
مركز الملك سلمان
في تطبيق بلدي او تتصل على الساعه 4:00 0
0 في عدم وجود اي معيار او متطلب لذوي
الاعاقه تبلغ في هذا البلابل
وفق الدليل المبسط اللي الهيئه طيب
بالاضافه سالت فيه كثير من مباني موجود
لكن الان في حال وجود نظام وجود مخالفات
هينات نقدر نحاسب او تقدر الجهات ممتاز
المسؤوله تحاسب عليها انت تعرف عن موضوع
التخفيض الخمسين في المياه اللي في
الطيران صح طيب انتم مش دوركم في بعض مثلا
مؤسسه او شركات الطيران غير ملتزم ثم اعطي
تضع شروط تقرا النظام بشكل او باخر جميل
يعني سؤال جميل
الخطوط السعوديه
المراحل كان في مرحله الحجز او في مرحله
صعود الطياره مرحله ال- في مرحله الطيران
كامله
وما زلنا ولو قلنا لك الان احنا همم يعني
همم
على اكمل وجه لا
مقصرين وبتضلوا مقصرين وهذا بيزيد طموحنا
باذن الله اننا بنزيد ان شاء الله العمل
على ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يعني كذلك
يجي اليوم اللي نقرا في قريبا
مثل ما قلت لك الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه الان
شغاله عليها
استراتيجيه وطنيه للاشخاص طيب انا هذه
مجموعه من من النقاط اسئله ويمكن حتى فيها
شكاوي انا ما عندي وقت عرضها المفروض كانت
رايحه عليك يعني بس هذه بخليها لك امانه
يعني انه انتم تعملوا على حل ابوابنا
مفتوحه والله ما عنده مشكله في الابواب
المفتوحه
يعني بشكل كويس
يعني كثير وما زالت وبتزال ان شاء الله
صدر
يحيى الموضوع يعني كان همم يحتمل كثير من
الاسئله والنقاش بكثير من الجوانب شكرا لك
على تواجدك اهلا وسهلا
زي ما قلت لك هذه الورقه فيها لبعض
الاسئله اتمنى من الهيئه انها تجيب عليها
باذن الله شكرا جزيلا لك راكان الجحنه
اخصائي الاعلام والتواصل الاجتماعي في
هيئه رعايه الاشخاص يعطيك العافيه باذن
الله
الامطار في الرياض الرابعه توثيق امتلاء
بحيره امام جبل الطويك
اهلا بكم من جديد انطلق مهرجان الحمضيات
في العلا من الاول من يناير حتى الحادي
والعشرين الذي يتزامل مع موسم الحصاد
ليتمتع بضيوف بتذوق اشهى انواع الحمضيات
الطازجه من المزارع المحليه وبصناف
الحمضيات ايمن فريده التي تحملها اكثر من
200 الف شجره مزدهره على ارض العليا
[موسيقى]
صحه العلا الثقافيه تحولت الى مقصد للزوار
من داخل المملكه وخارجها احتفاء بانطلاق
مهرجان الحمضيات ضمن فعاليات الشتاء
طنطوره
المياه المياه
وتحمل مع هدف جعل هذا المهرجان حدث
اقتصاديا اجتماعيا ينظم تحت اشراف الهيئه
الملكيه لمحافظه العلا والذي تقرر عقده
بشكل سنويا خلال شهريا تزامنا مع موسم
الحصاد و لتصليط الضوء داخليا وخارجيا على
منتجات العلا من الحمضيات ودعم التسويق
المنتجات الفريده لحمضيات العلاج
مع موسم حصاد الحمضيات في في العلا وهو
طبعا ينقسم الى قسمين قسم اجتماعي يهدف
الى زياده مداخيل الاسر المنتجه وايضا جمع
المزارعين بالاضافه الى اقتصادي
عقد صفقات
لشراء الحمضيات من همم مجموعه من المشترين
اللي تم دعوتهم
خبراء اعلاميون تم دعوتهم لتقديم وصفاتهم
القائمه على الحمضيات والتفاعل مع الخبرات
المحليه في مجال الطهي ايضا
منتجات العلا من الحمضيات على اختلافها
تحمل ارثا حضاريا وثقيا يعود للالاف
السنين كابترنش هنا الذي يحمل اهميه خاصه
لما تشير اليه الدراسات بانه كان محل
اهتماما من قبل الحضاره النبطيه حيث تم
تطويره عبر طرق التهجين وله اهميه خاصه في
الطب الشعبي عندما نتحدث عن الحمضيات
نتحدث عن ان انتاج الحمضيات في العلا يمثل
حوالي 30% من انتاج المملكه ككل وهذا ليس
بالرقم الوسيط ولا بالرقم السهل فاقامت
مهرجان الحمضيات ياتي ضمن رؤيه العلا وما
حفل به من مخطط رحله عبر الزمن للمحافظه
على الغطاء النباتي والغطاء الزراعي هنا
في المنطقه ليمثل رافضه اقتصاديا نادين
خماش العلا العربيه
ثلاثه بحيره ام شقوق الواقعه امام جبل
الطويق في مدينه الرياض بمياه الامطار
التي تشهدها مدن ومحافظات العاصمه هذا
الاسبوع كما تشهد ايضا المناطق شرق وغرب
شمال السعوديه امطار متفرقه بين متوسطه
وزيره
[موسيقى]
بحيره المشقوق في شمال الرياض العربيه
كيف المشهد عندك في مشروع كريم
محمد عبده
وتطعيس الوجه
يكفي انا طال عمرك وصوتك ههه
اتساع في كميه المياه الامطار اللي تشهدها
المناطق مختلفه من السعوديه كانت قبل عشره
اعوام لم تمتلى بحيره ام شقوق الواقعه
امام جبل طويق والعله الجبال التي نشاهدها
في الامام هناك هي سلسله جبال طويق طبعا
هذه البحيره هي تقع في شمال غرب العاصمه
الرياض طبعا كان اخر مدى لها في الحدود
التي وضعتها الجهات المعنيه من خلال وضع
الخرسانات على هذه المحميه وهي كونها
محميه من اجل الحفاظ على غطاء النباتي
وكذلك الطيور المهاجره ولكن الان نشاهد
كميه مياه الامطار قد خطت هذه المحميه
لتصل الى مسافات قريبه من جدا الان نتحدث
عن مساحه تتجاوز او تتجاوز طول البحيره
الان اكثر منول كيلو ونصف الكيلو متر وهي
يعني مساحه شاسعه لم تشهدها تحديدا بحيره
ام شقوق وهذا بدليل ان كميه الامطار التي
تجدها العاصمه الرياض او كذلك منطقه
الرياض همم كانت قد كانت كمياتها كبيره في
الاسبوع الحالي يعني لان كنا نتحدث مع
المتنزهين وكذلك همم دائما من المتنازين
الذي كانوا يقومون بزياره ام شقوق وايضا
استمتاع في مناظرها من خلال الغطاء
النباتي الموجود والتي قامت بها الجهات
المعنيه
بزياده زراعه اشجار الطلح والاثل وكذلك
الازهار المختلفه البريه التي تلائم
ومتلائ مع الطبيعه البريه هنا في هذه
المنطقه طبعا ايضا نتحدث عن عن مشروع اخر
هناك مشاريع في حمايه البيئه وكذلك
الزراعيه ولكن في الجهه الاخرى من جبال
طويق والعلام يمكن الحاله الضبابيه الان
التي تشهدها المنطقه هنا قد تغطي ملامح
بسيطه من جبال طويق اذكر ايضا ان ان كميات
الامطار ليس فقط كانت نشاهدها فقط على
البحيرات سواء فيهم مشكوك او كذلك
البحيرات الاخرى القريبه من منطقه الرياض
ولكن ايضا هذه الكثبان الرمليه او كانت
كثبان رمليه الان نشاهدها اقرب ما تكون
بحاله طينيه ونشاهد ايضا كلما حفرنا في
الاسفل نشاهد ما زالت كميه الرمال او كميه
الطين موجوده وهذا بدليل ان كميه الامطار
التي هطلت في هذه المنطقه كباقي مناطق
السعوديه التي تشهد امطار غزيره وكانت
ايضا التوقعات او التوقعات ما زالت مستمره
من قبل مركز الارصاد السعوديه الذي يقوم
بعمل تنبيهات متقدمه اضافه الى الجهات
المعنيه التي تطير منها اداره كاميرا شويه
ونشوف كمان الناس
راح نقوم بالتجول في البحيره الان ونتقدم
قليلا للبحيره هذه البحيره يعني الان او
نقف في منتصف البحيره وايضا لو يعطينا
المصور خالد ابو منصور
للجهه الاخرى من البحيره و نشاهد ايضا على
ارتفاعات عاليه همم هي همم السحب الرعديه
المنطره وتكون السحب الرعديه الممطره التي
ما زالت
مهيئه بهطول امطار ايضا غزيره على العاصمه
الرياض طبعا هناك منخفض جوي همم في
تحضيرات مركز الارصاد الذي يقوم بيئه
تنبيهاته مؤخرا والذي اشار الى ان فرص ان
ان الفرصه مهيئه بهطول امطار غزيره على
العاصمه الرياض لان نشوف عدد المتنازين
هنا قليل لان
معظم البحيرات المائيه الموجوده او
القريبه من مدينه الرياض امتلات فالناس
يقومون بالذهاب الى البحيرات الاقرب لهم
وهي فرصه سمحت للمتنزهين وسواء المقيمين
في العاصمه الرياض او كذلك سكانها او ايضا
السياسيه الذين قدموا الحضور والمشاهده
هذه البحيرات المائيه وعقبال عندك يا خالد
شكرا جزيلا
وهالطله الحلوه المنطقه
الى الرياض الان مع ليليان تنوري
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم افتتحت منافسات بطوله خليجي خمسه
22 بحرف المبهر امس دخل له عداد فقره
متنوعه شهد حفل الافتتاح عرضا فنيا
وغنائيا واخر الالعاب الناريه بحضور رئيس
وزراء العراق محمد شيعه السوداني الذي
اعلن افتتاح البطوله
رئيس الاتحاد الدولي وقدم مجموعه من
الفنانين العراقيين اوبريت هنا العراق هنا
البصره الذي يتغنى بهذه المدينه ومعالمها
واستعرضت نخبه اخرى تاريخها وحضارات في
بلاد الرافدين عبر لوحه تاريخيه مميزه كما
اشتمل الحفل على القاء قصائد شعريه
مع اطلاق اغنيه عراقيه تغنت بالمنتخبات
المشاركه في البطوله
افتتح منتخب العراق وعمان مشوارهما في
المجموعه الاولى امس من كاس من البطوله
لكره القدم في تعادل سلبي تبادل المنتخبان
الهجمات 90 دقيقه الا انهما اجزاء عن هذا
الشباك ينتهي اللقاء بدون اهداف ويضيف كل
منتخب نقطه واحده لرصده
تصدر المنتخب السعودي ترتيب المجموعه
الاولى بعد تغلبها على نظيره اليمني
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء في افتتاح مشوار
الفريقين بالبطوله سبحان النابت سجل الهدف
الاول لمنتخب السعوديه واضاف مصعب جوير
الهدف الثاني للاخضر من ركله جزاء يواجه
المنتخب السعودي نظيره العراقي في جوله
المقبله فيما يقابل منتخب اليمن المنتخب
العماني
معكم على منتخب الكويتي تحضيراته لمواجهه
مديره القطري في المجموعه الثانيه للبطوله
يدخل المنتخبان بظروف متشابهه على صعيد
الاستعانه بعناصر اغلبها لم يسبق لها
التواجد في دوره الخليج سبق ان نتوجه
الفريقان الكويتي والقطري في 18 مباراه
بدورات الخليج حيث فاز الازرق في 11
مباراه منها مقابل
وتعادل مره واحده
بعد الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم مدرب
المنتخب الاول حتى مونديال 2006 2020 اعلى
الاتحاد الفرنسي فان تجديد العقد جاء بعد
قياده المدرب منتخب فرنسا الى نهائي كاس
العالم في اخر نسختين وكان عقد الشون الذي
يستهل مشواره مع فرنسا عام 2012 كان قد
انتهى بعد مونديال قطر الاخير حيث حل حامل
اللقاب في مركز الوصيف وراء الارجنتين بعد
ركله الترشيح
يستقبل ليفربول فريق اول فرعون كان في
الدوري الثالث من كاس الاتحاد الانجليزي
في ملعب انفيلد الليله كشف المدرب لو بان
مدافع الهولندي برج الفان دايك سيغيب عن
الملاعب لاكثر من شهر بعد الاصابه في
اوتار الركبه التي تعرض لها امام
براندفورد يتاكد غيابه عن اربع مباريات
على الاقل وهي بالاضافه لهذا اللقاء
مواجهات برايتون وتشيلسي وليفربول
مرشح لظهور بقميص ليفربول للمره الاولى
في دوري ذاته يحل ضيفا على شكل دويتس داي
الذي يلعب في دور درجه الثانيه في ملعب
هيلز بروك لكاس لم يتلقى خساره في كافه
المسابقات بخمسه عشر مباراه متتاليه اخرها
تعادل مع ارسنال يحزن نقطه ثمينه على ملعب
الامارات في الجوله التاسعه عشر من الدوري
يحتل المركز الثالث بالترتيب 35 نقطه
متاخرا بتسعه نقاط عن ارسنال متصدر و4
نقاط عن مانشستر سيتي
ويتقدم بفرق الاهداف عن مانشستر يونايتد
الرابع طبعا هذا بترتيب الدوري
المدير الفني لريال مدريد قائمه فريقه
لمواجهه فياريال اليوم بملعب لا سيراميكا
ضد جوله السادسه عشر من دوري الاسباني
شهدت القائمه غياب ثلاثيه ظل وماريانو
دياز بسبب الاصابات يسار للانتزاع الصداره
من برشلونه الذي يتقدم عليه بفريق الاهداف
ويتساويان بعدد النقاط وهو 38
يسعى انتر ميلان مواصلات الضغط على نابولي
المتصدر عندما يحل ضيفا على منظر
جوله السابعه 10 من الدوري الايطالي كان
انت قدم عرضا قويا على ملعبه في جوله
الماضيه وتغلب على نابولي بهدف والسعاده
المدرب انزاجي خدمات البلجيكي روميو
لوكاكو بعد الاصابه التي ابعدته عن معظم
فترات القسم الاول من الدوري قبل مشاركته
في كاس العالم الماضي
ويستطيع يوفنتوس الضغط على نابولي ايضا
خاصه انه يواجه فريقا سهلا نسبيا في
المركز الثامن وهو اودي نازل على ملعب
اليا ستاديور في تورينو ربما يستعد اليجري
بعد لاعبيه المصابين امثال عن خادماريه
رونالدو
عن المباراه الاخيره
من نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم
خالد تفضل
[موسيقى]
شكرا
الجميل التي كانت بحيرات
في محميه الملك عبد العزيز قرب العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض متابعه معكم هذه الصور
[موسيقى]
ختم رابعه العلوي
على
وقع القمعي والاحتجاجات ايران تغير قائد
الامن الداخلي وانتقادات غربيه لاحكام
الاعدام
2023 اكثر من 400 اتفاقيه متوقع لتطوير
تجربه الحجاج معيشيا وثقافي
السعوديه من اعلى دول العالم اصابه بامراض
القلب 40,000 اصابه جديده في كل عام
جوله في مهرجان الحمضيات بالعلا 200000
شجره منتجه ودعم للمزارعين المحليين
وعلى وقع الامطار في الرياض الرابعه توثيق
امتلاء بحيره ام شقوق امام جبل طويق
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]